[Musique]
la chute du mur si la fin de la
dictature soviétique fin des privations
sein des atteintes aux libertés
mais le passage au capitalisme est très
rapide et parfois suivis dans l'ancienne
rda nos fruits étaient bon marché
aujourd'hui ils sont relativement chers
usines fermées chômage coût de la vie
certains allemands se met alors à avoir
le mal de l'est l'entr'aide le
plein-emploi l'affût rda et idéalisée et
l'ostalgie la nostalgie de l'est et son
apparition le stade j en allemagne sept
ans après la chute du mur de berlin
certains anciens citoyens est-allemands
éprouve donc une certaine forme de
nostalgie souvent parce qu'ils sont au
chômage
sous le régime communiste il avait au
moins une certaine sécurité de l'emploi
alors certains tentent de faire revivre
ne serait-ce qu'une soirée l'ambiance de
cette r d a fantasmé avec des fêtes où
l'on remet des vêtements de la rda où on
mange des produits de la rda et où l'on
chante des chansons de la rda les
flèches sous la rda qui n'était pas si
mal moi je me souviens avec plaisir de
cette période
c'est pour ça que je suis venu ce soit
en 1999 dix ans après la chute du mur
les allemands de l'est sont plus pauvres
caouette
le taux de chômage y est plus élevé et
l'ostalgie est encore bien présent
ils sont simplement déçu par la
démocratie derrière le gris du béton
l'air était moins verte qu'ils ne
l'avaient imaginé
les années passent et l'ostalgie devient
un business florissant hôtel remeubler à
la mode rda des années soixante dix
produits de consommation objets du
quotidien
un business juteux pour les touristes
mais pour les allemands de l'est les
désillusions persiste même 20 ans après
la chute du mur
à l'époque de la rda on n'avait pas peur
d'être au chômage
on savait faire face aux traites la
sécurité sociale était meilleure on
n'avait pas peur du lendemain chez nous
chanoine tonnes et 30 ans après alors
que certains n'étaient que des enfants
lorsque le mur est tombé
les soirées ambiance rda attirer encore
tout le monde avait un travail un
logement on allait bien et puis il y
avait de la solidarité entre les gens
aujourd'hui c'est terminé c'est chacun
pour soi
depuis la réunification trente ans après
la réunification
la déchirure est ouest n'est pas
refermer complètement
[Musique]